الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
آه
أنت تبتسم
أنت تعرفه جيدًا ، من الواضح أنك
قد تعاملت معه ،
نعم ، احتمال أن يصبح رئيسًا
مرة أخرى ، ما رأيك في
اعتقادك أنه سيرشح نفسه ، إنه
يحاول ، هل تعتقد أنه سيفعل ذلك؟  أهرب من
معرفتك ، سوف يركض ، نعم ، سيرشح نفسه
،
هل سيفوز أم لا ، هذه
استطلاعات الرأي في الانتخابات الأمريكية ستقول ما الذي
تعلمته منه وهو يتعامل معه
جيدًا أو سيئًا ،
أجده محترفًا
أه
يعرف أن وظيفته تسير على ما يرام  بالتفصيل
ما تعلمته
منه أيضًا خلال فترة رئاسته
عندما تفاعلت معه عدة مرات
غداء أو عشاء
، وكنت مندهشًا من الركض في
العالم الذي تديره أنت كرئيس للعالم
كم كان مرتاحًا في وجبات الغداء
والعشاء أو  عندما يلعب الجولف
ولا يبدو الأمر كما لو أنه يدير أكثر
المؤسسات أو المقعد تعقيدًا
في العالم